et en actes et leurs girafes très
content pour ça je vais vous dire
pourquoi et on va tout jouer
ok limite qui sépare du nom gerra il ya
un instant julien courbet disais que
vous étiez le plus grand imitateur de
tous les temps c'est gentil
c'est vrai je vous aimerai la voix les
mimiques et 3 des voix que personne ne
fait alors voir pour lui demander de le
faire parce qu'elle abaissait mais par
exemple quand il fait brett sinclair et
danny way vous fermez les yeux tu l'as
eu tort il y a des très bons autour de
la table je sais faire moundir là c'est
vous dire vous perdez dans l'écran il ya
huit imitation jeu ses limites et
brigitte bardot juste limité valérie
damidot je sévis jane birkin je sais me
tais christophe lambert je suis animé
jusqu'à destin il ya que des imitations
jeunes bien l'envoya qui autour de la
table ses limites et brigitte bardot à
votre avis l'on vous et nora enora
malagré mfs il les aime et fais ce leur
droit européen
mss hanouna tu les aimes effet sert il
du coup c'est à dire que cette fois son
buteur
ça tout le temps je veux te faire toutes
les missions si tu veux aller au petit
chat se mettre en banque lambert parce
que là à l'onem muret va pas tomber tout
seul
la marge venir va lui mettre les dames
système est contre un mur
el murr ses formes pourquoi parce que
c'est plus intelligent qui sème le
premier moi je te dis moi excuse moi
c'est avec aisance et bon vivant à gaza
du coup j'ai pas vu la vidéo j'ai
l'impression que l'on a dit bouteille à
la concurrence qui arrive c'est énorme
c'est le rire de christophe lambert
d'highlander c'est quoi c'est tout
allez-y en fait le message je sais
imiter valéry giscard d'estaing
ballard fait le renom
bonsoir madame bourgeois mademoiselle
bon choix monsieur assez sympa si la
limite est le leur on sait qui je suis
vite et jean pierre foucault
moi je sais limité quand il fait l'amour
à sa femme qu'il fait l'amour avec sa
femme et il allume la lumière et la
musique démarre attention gérer le
dernier palier avant l'orgasme la
position amoureuse que nous sommes
contraints de l'arctique et s'appelle à
la levrette bête la choupinette - chérie
tu veux appeler un ami jean paul
belmondo c'est lui donc français ben oui
vous vous imitez jean paul belmondo non
mais je vais essayer de voir ça ait un
tabac
[Musique]
viens donc apparemment à ibiza gratter
ce boulot c'est pas beau ça vient
d'apporter leurs girafes très content
pour ça non je vous dit pourquoi
au début j'étais pas pour je l'aurais
dit je veux pas de l'eau rougie région
vous dire pourquoi ce que laurent gerra
il a rien à faire ici
voilà c'est tout merci
c'est là qu'on doit tous laurent gerra
même a du talent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]